[Music]
[Applause]
76ers against the Celtics in Boston Suns
at the Nuggets Reggie Miller will be on
the call tonight 76ers Celtics in Boston
7 30 Eastern on TNT we were talking
about can't miss players and we were
mentioning of quite a few guys who was
the NBA player or least college player
and you went that guy's going to be a
star when he goes to the NBA
I would say David Robinson
well no somebody who didn't turn out to
be a star who did not yeah yeah like we
threw out a bunch of guys that you know
like Michael Beasley O.J Mayo stromale
Swift Harold Martin here's one I thought
was a no can and he he Bears the same
name as mine and he was in my same draft
Reggie Williams from Georgetown you
remember Reggie Williams remember as a
freshman
he was he was on those great Georgetown
teams with Coach Thompson
um I believe won one Championship with
him
um he had all the talent could shoot
play great defense could handle uh had
length and I just thought for sure he
was going to be an unbelievable Pro but
for whatever reason it didn't pan out
okay but why is it you can be really
good in college
and you're playing the same game but it
doesn't translate into the NBA because
the NBA is a different type of game
there's a different type of physicality
um you know that's a great question
because players that were unbelievable
college players and it is pretty much
the same game but it's played a diff
it's a much faster Pace uh the guys are
bigger stronger yeah and there's not a
lot of room for error so you almost get
left behind if you can't flip the page
very quickly
um not to say that Reggie couldn't flip
the page very quickly but sometimes you
just get lost in the cracks but like
Kevin Love
how do you explain that
but he was a good college player but but
good but then he averaged like 25 and 13
or 27 and 13 and then he became a
three-point shooter like how do you
explain that learning to adapt with the
times I you know I throw like Brook
Lopez from Milwaukee when he was at
Stanford him and his brothers they were
good they were okay but Brook Lopez
transformed his game very much the same
way Kevin Love did his first like six or
seven years he shot like 53s his last
seven years he shot like almost a
thousand threes he transformed his game
along with the the way the style of the
NBA is
your reaction uh the Joker getting 25
000 fine not suspended and nothing
happening to the sun's owner I'm I'm
still kind of shaking my head on that
um because I believe if that hadn't been
the owner of the Phoenix Suns I don't
think this would have been that big of
an issue but because it was an owner
um because if the owner is not holding
the ball like that and he just
immediately gives it to Joker or throws
it to the referee none of this happens I
think the league is kind of overreacting
here because if that was a bit of normal
fan that fan would have been tossed
so it's coming one of the fans got
tossed who did place his hand on Joker
so somebody who was right there with the
owner of the sons did get tossed
um and I'm sure it was a friend of the
owners look again I think the league
overreacted and I love the response by
the owner of the of the Phoenix sunset
look this should not be uh talked about
I don't want my name in this
uh jokic is a great player and the focus
should be on this fabulous series that
we're having right now that's tied to
two all right let's uh let's talk about
the Warriors and the Lakers last night
what stood out for good or bad I I'm
still scratching my head on how Golden
State lost that ball game I give all the
credits to the Lakers for hanging around
um obviously the story today is Lonnie
Walker and his contributions Off the
Bench
but
defensively the way that
golden state was able was Steph
playing really the point guard position
and carving them up on that high screen
enroll uh with ad in it
I'm still wondering how they they lost
that ball game to me
and in their championship year last
season Jordan full was that third X
Factor for them he's been non-existent
in these playoffs and I don't know what
has happened to his game but they are
very top-heavy with Steph and clay and
when those two guys have to play defense
which the Lakers are making them play
defense because it looks like Steph is
having to guard LeBron on every screen
and roll and it's wearing them down they
need a third score and Wiggins has tried
to do it but we expected Jordan Poole to
be that guy and he just hasn't been
um so I I'm not here to say that this
series is over for Golden State I will
give the Champs
um somewhat of a leash but I will say
that they are on life support right now
and it's it's getting close to the end
you know the Lakers play good defense
yeah and even that play where they knew
Draymond was going to drive they're down
three LeBron has A.D switch out to Clay
in the corner
and you know Draymond had no place to
throw it so that to me a great Scouting
Report let Draymond go he's not going to
shoot and then he's going to try to kick
it out for the three and they defended
it uh and I thought A.D a couple of
times switching out on Steph Curry
making the degree of difficult even
greater by trying to get it over A.D I
thought they did a uh it wasn't pretty
but they did a wonderful job and you
know
pulling out that win and you're not
going to get you know and who cares if
you went ugly right and bottom line is
if you win and at times that length you
mentioned it on the switching out with
A.D uh yeah Steph's gonna make some he
had that four point play that was
unbelievable on on a play just like that
but you're playing percentages
and finally you know when you're at this
level in the playoffs
um it's good to see players and coaches
because let's give Darvin ham and his
staff a lot of credit because that last
play that you're mentioning you know how
many times they've gone over that in
scattering reports and this is when you
finally get to figure out who's paying
attention in the back during these film
sessions right some guys are sleeping
some guys are on their phone now you're
figuring out who's paying attention and
the in the Lakers and everyone was on
the same page on that play know your
personnel know the Tendencies of who
you're playing against
and they played it to a t okay but how
does Lonnie Walker the fourth quarter
we're calling him uh how does how does
that happen that that you know he was a
decent player during the regular season
I think got what 12 points but you have
this game in this moment against this
team
it's about staying ready and if you
remember Lonnie Walker was playing a
major minutes early on this year I
believe started a few games as well and
he was going to be counted on as part of
this young up and coming Corps along
with Austin Reeves
um to to help LeBron and A.D fell out of
the rotation but for all you young
players out there who's riding the bench
who's been in and out of the lineups
here's the storybook ending right here's
a guy whose number has not been called
at all during the playoffs spot minutes
and you get in in the biggest moments
and you have the quarter of your career
on the biggest moment against the
defending champs
I mean what what better way you know to
when people say play your minutes hard
stay ready you never know what the coach
is thinking case in point Lonnie Walker
IV
Reggie Miller the Hall of Famer will be
on the call tonight game five in Boston
the 76ers Celtics 7 30 Eastern on TNT
we brought this up a little while ago Al
Horford
I think is a Hall of Famer
because I factor in the two national
titles he won at Miami
all right so the Basketball Hall of Fame
or Florida I should say the Basketball
Hall of Fame
six-time All-Star
are you with me on that that he will be
a Hall of Famer if we're factoring in
college which they do you do uh and I'm
glad you clarified that because I want
people to understand when you go into
the Basketball Hall of Fame it embodies
your whole career not just your MBA
right so you're right two championships
six-time All-Star it's been to numerous
Conference Finals with Atlanta Hall of
Famer
I don't know if the numbers are there if
you're supported
he he's done he's certainly not a first
or second even third time no no but I
think eventually
yes you can make a case for those
numbers what's his total points right
now is he getting close to 20 000
because if he's not close to 20 000 I
don't know I don't think he's going to
be close Polly Polly where what what is
he in total points right now oh I always
have his point total at the top of my
head right thirteen thousand six okay
yeah he's not a Hall of Famer no no no
no no is Joe Johnson a Hall of Famer oh
good one
seven time All-Star 20 000 points
[Music]
the knocking
knocking that's a good one very good one
nobody hit a 15-foot jumper like Joe
Johnson did oh and you're talking
ice water in his veins no in terms of
closing out games Joe Johnson he doesn't
get talked about enough in terms of
money in the bank when it matters the
rich he doesn't get talked about it all
not at all nobody is bringing up Jojo
even in Joe Johnson's household nobody's
bringing it up no he's bringing it up
how about okay Blake Griffin
no
first half he was on his way
well you know it he has chapters still
being raped because
hey if if they end up winning a
championship with Boston
that counts on your resume yeah but he's
averaging for a game right he's
averaging four a game but it counts on
you he won a championship see well what
do you want you got to win a
championship being the man well wait a
minute the Lakers say they're going to
give Patrick Beverly a championship ring
if they win a title come on Reg
Blake Griffin's getting four it's a
participatory trophy for him he's
averaging four a game
how about Sean Kemp
no six-time All-Star
nope
one time final been in the finals one
time with Seattle LaMarcus Aldridge
oh man
wow but no okay all right okay okay no
um Jermaine O'Neal
these are just names off the top of my
head he's in the same boat to me as like
Lamarcus silk consecutive All-Star
appearances
and oh man he was almost close to
defensive player of the year and he
carried you for years he did defense he
did
it's because I'm a homer you mean
because I'm a homer oh yeah you don't
mean it you don't mean it's going in
Amari Stoudemire
strong case
but no okay
yeah Brad Daugherty
yeah Brad's not already in
I don't think so
I don't think so I will put you like
this if Brad Doherty played in today's
game with today's rule
he would be the Joker
10.0
he would so dominate in today's game
Brad Daugherty well
The Unbelievable skills footwork could
face you up yeah play with his back to
the basket uh assist like Mark Price
Mark Price would dominate in today's
game the those Cleveland Cavaliers team
with Craig Lilo and Larry Nance oh my
God they would be unbelievable in
today's game Mark Price long forgotten
but you know you look back on his career
and
like you almost have to see the
highlights where you go damn he was he
was doing some damage
but but you know he was only a four-time
All-Star but one of the the great
Shooters great great shooters that we
had and quick off the dribble and pick
and roll think about him in the pick and
roll those High pick and rolls oh him
and Dougherty it was yeah yeah my Pacers
we did not want to see them Jimmy Butler
Hall of Famer yes okay and he and he's
acting like Hall of Famer again yeah
Jimmy Butler will be in the hall how
does it
know that that's the guy the Knicks know
that's the guy and they still can't stop
the guy
and not only that especially with hero
being lost for the playoffs he's the
only I wouldn't say he's the only one I
mean bam is serviceable
um Lowry is a shell of himself but he is
the guy and you know what it's called
Dan will
he's just got will he's got it man
he's got it and okay is this the ceiling
for the Knicks reg let's be honest
is this as good as it's going to get for
the Knicks are they a second round team
I think they're
one more piece away from being a
championship Contender too uh continuing
team I love Jalen Brunson I don't think
Julius Randle is as healthy as
he should be at this time of year RJ
Barrett is playing okay for them but
they have nothing in the middle
um
really no shooting guard yeah but if
you're saying you got one guy you got to
get that one guy well who's the one guy
I mean are you gonna get Zion Williamson
he's I gotta play 30 40 games for me
that's not gonna do no I can't rely as
much as I love Zion
he he has to show me he can play
not 82. can he play 70 games would you
trade for Dame Dame Lillard yes
now to me that could help take the
Knicks to that next level but I'm sure
Brooklyn is saying the same thing I've
seen him in Brooklyn I see him in
Brooklyn more than I do the Knicks if
he's on either one of those New York
teams they are title continuing teams in
the east
with their current roster with that
current roster I mean Dame averaged 32
this year but he and he's a closer I
know he's an absolute closest but at
what point do you say
I gave you everything
and we're not going anywhere
how about we just divorce how about you
let me go and try to win a championship
and you guys rebuild and and try to find
the next Dame Lillard and the Blazers
should do that he can't come out and say
it not publicly but he can go to
management
yeah but things like that still get on
their own the Blazers should be doing
that they really should hey thank you
for your service we tried we tried and
it just it's we're going to try to get a
boatload of picks and maybe some players
this year for you where would you like
to go by the way I would ask him too
give me a list of five teams where you
think you would like to go my friend
what do you expect out of James Harden
tonight in this game
you know we were just talking about this
in our production meeting and
in the two wins he is 33 for 53 and the
two losses five for 28. yeah right so
the over under is 21 and a half I'll put
you like this I want to see the Vegas
James Hart I wanna because after that
after he went to Vegas that game won he
went crazy I want to see that type of
attacking because when he is at his best
that means Max D and Tobias Harris are
involved I know indeed what indeed's
gonna do but to me the gauge of this
series for Philadelphia is James Harden
he's got to be Houston James Harden and
not Brooklyn James Harden
don't be afraid to tonight with Kevin
Harlan when Al Horford blocks Joellen
Beach shot again that you go you know
what Kevin we have to start looking at
him as maybe a Hall of Famer if you
factor in what he did in college Reg
I mean as I spoke earlier with my
girlfriend Dan Patrick are you saying
he's the Hall of Famer he's going to be
a Hall of Famer
I think you'll be a Hall of Famer not at
thirteen thousand well I'll put it like
this you and I won't be a lot you and I
won't be alone yes I will yes I will
wait
who gets in first Joe Johnson or Al
Horford Joe Johnson will go in before
Al Horford it's Tyler Hansbrough a Hall
of Famer no well you see all-time
leading scorer and rebounder in ACC
history College Hall of Fame yes no is
Derrick Rose a Hall of Famer
yes
he had three great years
Is He To This Day the youngest MVP ever
yeah he's going in he's going in
yeah he had three great years three
great years and one of those years he
won it was the youngest MVP ever okay
he's going in all right fair enough all
MVPs they're almost like ushered in
every MVP has been is has been in the
hall of fames every MVP is in the Hall
of Fame Polly look it up no probably
true probably true
in the Hall of Fame so don't be afraid
when Horford does something nice tonight
just to say you know what Kevin he he
might be a Hall of Famer when he said
I'm going to bring this up on air
tonight when when he does something okay
I expect to do something tonight I'm
gonna bring that up to Mr Harlan and see
how he reacts he blocked him beads
jumper a couple of times Reg
so that's all you know I'm saying how
does that happen embiid gets his jumper
blocked by Al Horford
Al Horford is a great defender
he can't I don't think so he can't jump
it's all about timing you don't have to
be a great leaper to have great timing
wait watch you just call Al Horford a
great defender great Defenders go to the
Hall of Fame
so he's a great defender two-time
national champ
six seven time All-Star
Al Horford Mr excitement
he'll get in it's just you and I will
not be around you to see that
it won't be the first second third he'll
get in eventually
it's one of those one of those type
selections all right
well we'll be listening waiting for a
shout out of course of course we're
we're gonna well he's gotta do something
for him to get the shout out for me to
bring you out
Al Horford is going to be doing
something tonight okay he better part of
my open he better be once again this is
how it might sound tonight at the Boston
Garden Al Horford from the corner and
the Celtics have taken a 1916 lead
they're on a 5-1 run timeout Philly this
is the NBA on TNT
Kevin gets excited over little things
thank you reg appreciate your theater
Reggie Miller he'll be on the call
tonight with Kevin Harlan at the Garden
7 30 Eastern on TNT last call for phone
calls we're back after this